here now to respond there's a lot to
deal with here former acting director of
national intelligence rick grinnell uh
rick thank you very much for being here
with me i do i do appreciate it what is
your take here as we've learned more
about the ghani conversation legacy
media has kind of ignored what ghani
told the president what's your
assessment of what all this is leading
up to here
i
am not surprised that washington d.c is
lying to us again unfortunately tammy we
have a situation where washington dc's
politics has literally killed americans
and while this can go on in washington
and those in washington can paper it
over and try to spin that they got 90
percent
of americans out of afghanistan the rest
of us outside of washington
are saying we've never seen a situation
where washington dc politicians are
proud of 90
what we hear
what the rest of us here is you left 10
of the people in afghanistan and you're
trying to spin this
i i really never thought that i would
see this moment come now we have
intelligence officers who are leaking
against democrats it's so bad
and i i don't like that i don't like
when intelligence officers do
but they did it constantly against
president trump now they're doing it
against joe biden i think what we have
now tammy is it's less of republican
versus democrat right now as fighting
and it's washington versus the rest of
america you know every great
civilization has lasted roughly 250
years
we're butting up against that i think
it's shame on us this has happened to us
so many times we americans we've got to
stop apologizing we've got to stop
pretending like washington dc is ever
going to change itself it's not it's not
changing itself we have to get involved
ronald reagan told every generation you
got to fight for your freedom and i
think everybody listening to us tonight
has got to rise up they've got to
realize washington isn't changing you've
got to change washington you got to dig
a a trench
so that we can get fresh water into
washington i love lisa mclean yeah
because she's a freshman congresswoman
from michigan
she's perplexed that washington is like
this and i love that she will continue
to fight that's what we need we need
people to go to washington who look at
the place and say what
yeah and rick i mean but that's what we
all have to do there is a tendency here
to retreat in general and that's what
the swamp wants that's what this monster
wants
they want to exhaust us and we we
understand i mean being in there itself
uh is got to be difficult but as
americans we've got to continue to be
heard we've got to continue to make sure
that our the people in our community
know what we feel we've got to stand in
front of this and just like when we
think about 90 were saved it shows you
that this government certainly the biden
administration looks at human beings as
hashtags on a piece of paper
and and it's 90
10
your fat content you know i mean are you
kidding me
look i think that people have got to
stop uh worrying about canceled culture
it's time that we fight back when you
hear somebody stand up stand with them
support them because they can't cancel
all of us and the reality is we're half
the economy we're half
the population probably a little bit
more get active speak up don't be alone
and thank you sir i mean that's a great
point because frankly it's more than 80
of us are outraged about this so it's
it's it's we're beyond 50 at this point
rick thank you very much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else